and alec manoa is back off the injured
list alec will get ready for his ninth
career big league start but his first
since july the ninth 22 days since manoa
last pitched in the major leagues
because of the back injuries suffered in
buffalo
and this ball's drilled the left center
field sinking lighter and the catch is
made
what a play by lourdes gurio jr
on a ball that looked like all kinds of
trouble
you know again
first time back in a couple of days in
the outfield
very windy
in last night's ball game very windy
down on the field again today and this
one was playing games this ball with the
win was playing games with lourdes
curiel verlorda stays with it
2-2 to perez swinging in a miss and he
got him with a fastball
manoa's first strikeout in toronto and
we'll see how mike miner does this time
around against the blue jays he's coming
off back-to-back quality starts miner
ready springer ready
springer ready
high in the air to left field
[Music]
that's the 40th career of leadoff home
run for george springer and it's the
39th home run for the blue jays this
year on the first pitch of an at-bat and
that leads the major leagues and fairly
comfortably like that
and they're breaking out the jacket
early this afternoon alejandro kirk the
right-handed hitter minor out of the
wine the 2-2
bounce towards the hole on the left side
and through into left field
alejandro kirk with his second hit of
the series
kirk at first with one down and a 2-1
count on george springer who homered his
first time up
now he might have done it again
he did
on cue
he really you know
it was unfair to expect a guy to be out
as long as he was in just kind of drop
him right back into major league action
no matter how great a player you are
and i think what we've seen is he just
keeps getting better the more he plays
and
certainly one of the better players in
the league so it's exciting to have him
in the lineup now
he mentioned that to us yesterday that
he felt like he had just finished spring
training when it came to timing and
seeing the ball how his body felt
and he says i i feel really good i
really feel like the regular season is
just starting for us
came into the game with the 290 era in
nine major league outings ground ball to
short backhanded to bechet
right on the money with the throw and
the royals go one two three eight in a
row now set down by alec manoa
there's a good confidence builder right
there breaking ball on the outside
corner to pick up the strikeout i think
finding a routine that works for you
i think learning the league learning the
big league
lifestyle
he's a strike throw he's a big guy who
can throw strikes he's got a very simple
delivery
and he rings up another one here
[Applause]
alec manoa is rolling he's retired 11 in
a row
santana is just the second runner
1-0 bouts towards vlad a soft hopper
handled by the first baseman he says
stop to manoa he wants to take it
himself and he does alec manoa retiring
14 in a row
and again a bit of an mvp chan here at
rogers center
broken the bat ground ball dozier to his
left
bounces it across
out is the call
the crowd does not agree and let's see
what the blue jays video room has to say
about that i am sure they are going to
take a look at this one absolutely
foots down
ball's not in the picture i don't see it
yeah
headsets coming off
safe
marcus is over two in a couple of fly
balls to right field
poke to right center field that's a base
hitting it's getting to the wall
guerrero's on his way to third he's
going to come in to score simeon into
thirds standing up
and it is four to nothing
well that's what you will learn
in this ballpark if you are going to go
dive for a ball you better either catch
it or knock it down
or that baby's going to go to the wall
that's going to be extra basis
simbra was warming up when he came into
the game watch the left of your screen
simeon carrera
if only these guys could loosen up and
have a little fun while they're playing
hey and there's a base hit into left
field and that's an 11-game hitting
streak for whitmer field
and his first ever hit against simber
top of the order let's see if the boys
can get back in this game here late yeah
this little rado man that's laredo
fastball middle didn't sink to it with
what's able to turn on it some top spin
gets it through the infield quickly
same thing it's all about fun
fans having some fun too simber with a
big strikeout and a couple of runners
stranded
laddie one for three and infield hit his
last time up stay on that slider away
[Applause]
high indeed to right center field did he
get enough
just short taylor on the track two down
to getting the blue jays back in town
there's an elevated fastball strikeout
for simber his second in a row
and mark gave us a little intel on on
that that the move and all the people he
had to talk to the government how that
works
and you're right a big sigh of relief
that they are back in town
he hasn't thrown a bowl yet
right on the outside corner two down
[Applause]
i also like that he finished off the
eighth inning he's warm let him finish
today
and the blue chase and out away
[Music]
and the blue jays are 2-0 now back at
home